Y
WE WITH
AISSIA.N THIS MOG WITH AAPPETHR
UKRAINIA ARE
FIGHTINGILITARY ONN TROOMOVED
SECOND
LARGESCITY.
INAUSE
FIGHTING TE  S CLAIME
D ON
ARGETS BUT SEEE TOOO, S.ZESING N
UK
,
BOARRAERTY
COUNTRY OCCUPANABLE TAR>> THI C
ITS EUARE WORKING ITNAESO SLOW
RUSSN ESAG T
CUT OFF NK
Y FO
WORLDWIDE TELECOMMICUR ARE
COVERINGHERYL
ANGLES.
ALEX MARQUARDT, FOR US  KYIV.
FIGHTING HNT ACROSS
UKRATAE GH
G EXPLOSIONS FAR
TANDING RIGHT NOW.
BRING US SPEEDH N 'RE SEEING.
r:IN NOT JUST ACRO T
UNE CITY AS
WELL.
IN THE PASS
APPEAR TO N ACCERABOMBARDMENT.
MA DE ON RHOTEL, AND F
DISTANCE, TO THE
O TH.IONS THA BEEN
ON THERE ARE AISNCE
PLUMES
ESSEIACK
FEW RROW
YOU CAN CERTAINLE THAT
IT COULD BTHIS IS  LOUDER DAY,F
YOU WI YTE
COMES AFT LASNIT GO THAT THERE
D HAVE BEEWI
BSS
PLANES OVER
THAT DIDT IAZEBUTHNIFICAEXPLOSIT
SOUTHWEST, NE KSECOND BIGGE
THE FIRST ONE REING IN A
MASSIVE .
YOU ULE D R MON 12
YOU CAN STILLEE E SMOK THAT.TH
INTENSIFYING.S ALSO
WE KNOTRTTN RUSSIAD
UKRAINIAN FOING TOLD T INSIDE.RS
OUT.
THE UKRAINIARC
BTTING UPFIGHT.IS IS DA.E D TO
UL48.THE UK
GHT.
RUSSIAN PERSONNEE BEING PONRY, .
EYIFFICULTIE
THIS IS CLEA ALL-OUT
FIGHT FOR TH
EVERYTHING.IT ISAR SIANIMEY ARE
HEAITANOT SI TARGET TH
RESULT, ZELENSKYY H
ISED THIS CALL TO ARJUST FORAN
SANGTHEY ARE CREG TE SO WANT CA
AGAIT .
ORIS, CHRE.  D GOOD CAREF UR C
SECOND LARGEST CITARE URGING,
IN DON'T USE THE FIGHTING
THETS.
KE T
KHARKIV NOD CNRTER WHO
APPEARS TO BTHE
TV ROR THAT ,
FIREFIGHADARIA, YOU AND YOUHOLK
WAUGH WHATOUEXPECIERE ARE.
>>
THANK YOU FOR HAVING
TO THE H.NDS ARE SECURE COEES C
RIGHT NOW, A
THE WOODEN DESKSORCLOSEDANSO T
OP H JUST MOVED STUFF BACK TE  N
WINDOWS,ECHE WGEM OUTSIDE, FROM
TIME TO TI HEALOUD
GUNSHOTS.
BASIY SHOULD B ALSO R ROUND   TR
>> Reporter: YEAH, IS
AROUNDBUOFOU YOU W
BECAUSE OF SWE DON'TW IFRINOE GE
WE'RE THINKI O
>> TDA
DON, S T THT'S H POLAND.N 0 PE
UKE,Y  T ANGOTHERS
.
THIS
MORNING?
>> Reporter:T'
EXTR EVERY
SINGLE PERU
IREMEMBERS THERTAINERIENC
HAVEEY LOVFTM
BEHIND NOT JUSGHEPONIME THE FA
AND HAVE
SO ARRIVAL I
DIRECTIOMA
THEM WOULDE N THG ABWAITING OUT
TEMPERATURES, WITH NO
OD WATERAT
WITH LITTLE  TT O THE
RDERFROM THEC AND THE EMNA, IT
O THR DE
W,E THEYUALLY GET
HEME T
VARIOUS PTE MI IENDS.
BUT THEN YOU ALS
OL
'LLDP SIGNS UP,
ADVERTISING LEHOG CAN GEEEO, WH
Y FOR FREE.
COIT YOU ACTUALL
T
MAKES THEIPERIENCENYS
AGIZWE HAVSISTER FATR HI
WE
COPE
CHILDRENWH
IND.
SOE TOLD THEIR IL DADDY IGOING
UT HOPE,
L TRYINGBE
HEIRRE
O
D EV
D TODAY, IUST WANT
UKRAINE, AND NOW THE AINTRR AGO
IS.
LIUKRAIN AEAN DISPD
HO WASM
REGION, THATAS UNDERTI CE HAD FD
EN THE OTHERIDE,ICST GETNG TE MS
SOMETHINAT
HAS TO B
ERZATION THE